well as you can see i can't move
last wednesday at windsor castle and the
queen could not have seemed on better
form albeit unusually admitting to
having trouble standing but now we know
the 95 year old has tested positive for
covert 19. the palace confirmed her
majesty is experiencing mild cold-like
symptoms but expects to continue light
duties at windsor over the coming week
she will continue to receive medical
attention and will follow all the
appropriate guidelines
it's always unsettling when you hear
that there is anything wrong with the
queen
and i think that on this occasion
the word kovid sets a bit of a shudder
but the palace has been very clear that
she is only suffering mild cold-like
symptoms and she'll be going back to
light duties next week and i think that
in its own way
is reassuring
tweeting about the news boris johnson
said i'm sure i speak for everyone in
wishing her majesty the queen a swift
recovery from covid and a rapid return
to vibrant good health while kierstamas
said on behalf of myself and the whole
of uk labour wishing her majesty the
queen good health and a speedy recovery
get well soon mom
ah there you are throughout the pandemic
everything possible has been done to
protect her engagements went online only
a small staff nicknamed hms bubble were
allowed close to her at windsor castle
and as restrictions eased events were
still kept socially distanced and
outdoors like captain tom moore
receiving his knighthood
the royal family have seen it as their
responsibility to set the right example
and the queen wanted it to be known
publicly she had had her vaccine and
encouraged others to do the same
it is obviously difficult for people to
if they've never had a vaccine because
they ought to think about other people
rather than themselves
[Music]
but there have been other worries about
her health last october the day after
this global investment summit she had to
cancel a trip to northern ireland spent
the night in hospital and then was told
to rest by doctors she subsequently
missed remembrance sunday after she
sprained her back which is why there was
added concern when it was announced two
weeks ago that prince charles had
coveted and had seen his mother
initially it was oh like no no please so
i googled it and saw that she just had
mild symptoms so
it's like a sigh of relief i think she's
she's a tough cookie she's survived
through a lot so
i'm really not concerned about her at
all i think she would be okay because
she's probably in good hands good
positions
in recent weeks she could not have
seemed happier spending time in norfolk
for accession day it was a message of
reassurance from the palace after the
recent health scares
a sign of her determination to carry on
which they'll continue to want to stress
now she has covered
rhiannon mills sky news in windsor
[Music]